ERIC ERNST: I'm Eric Ernst.
I'm on the language team, and
I really enjoyed Leaf's talk
this morning.
But I wanted to interject
a little bit extra here,
a little extra point of
view that he didn't cover.
So there is this issue of how
to specify the foundations
of this language.
How do we make sure that we
understand what the language is
in the first place?
So for that, we have the
language specification,
and the language specification
was published as ECMA-408
last summer.
And we're working on the
language specification,
and we have a lot of updates
in the current version that's
in GitHub.
And then we have these
feature specifications
that specify the new
features, and they're all
going to be folded into the
language specification proper.
But one element in the
language specification
that is a little bit difficult
to get an overview over
is the specification
of the grammar
because what we have
in the specification
there is a lot of snippets.
So basically, we
have these snippets
all over the specification,
and some of these snippets
have a couple of issues
that we knew about.
For instance, there
were some places
where metadata could
be placed in two
locations in a declaration.
That was clearly
not intended, so we
had a need to make sure that
we knew that this specification
was actually correct.
So instead of having a
lot of textual snippets
and then letting
everybody who's working
on the implementation of a tool
work based on these snippets
and rely on them
100%, we would want
to have some direct feedback on
the correctness of the grammar
itself, the whole grammar.
So basically, I set out to
create this specification
parser, which is a parser that
has a complete Dart grammar,
and that Dart
grammar is something
that we are going to use to feed
back into the specification.
So we want to know that the
grammar is, itself, consistent,
for instance, that it
has ambiguity properties
that we know about.
We're not going to get rid
of all the ambiguities.
We're going to say
how to resolve them.
We also want to make sure
that the specification
grammar matches the
actual Dart source code,
so we can run this
tool, which is
a parser that is generated
by the ANTLR 3 tool, parser
generator.
And then we can see that the
specification of the grammar,
as we specify it in
this grammar file,
will actually match the
source code out there.
This is, as I mentioned,
a specification
in a particular tool,
this ANTLR tool,
so that means that
it is not something
that we're going to make the
specification of the grammar
of the language because it
has accidental properties.
It's an ANTLR V3
thing, but still, we're
going to use it as input.
So we have a couple
of rules here
from this specification grammar.
That is what we're using to
generate the specification
parser from.
So if you compare that
with the previous version,
we had here a function
body, and the function body
is very much the same.
Now, it's a little bit
different in the syntax
because it's a
specification that
fits ANTLR V3 instead of the
ad hoc format that is used
in the language specification.
But if you look at
the type, then it
used to be type name
and type arguments,
and that's now a lot
different because we've
integrated the inline function
types that Leaf mentioned.
So we are able to
write function of int
instead of writing a typedef and
then referring to that typedef,
so that means that we have
a number of constructs
that are considerably more
complex now than they used
to be.
And for instance,
down there, you
have something like a Type Not
function, which is the old type
as you knew it, and
then it has the function
keyword separately.
And the reason why we have
that is that we cannot allow
function to be an ordinary type
name because then you could
give it type arguments, and then
it would be ambiguous whether
we were currently reading a
function type or we're reading
something that just uses
functions as the name
of a class.
So we have a number of cases
where we need to disambiguate,
and this is something
that happens
in different ways in
the specification,
the big document,
150-page document.
So the symbol literal at
the top is one good example.
So basically, if you
have something like Foo
dot Bar dot To String,
that could be a symbol that
has three elements,
but it could also
be a symbol that's
Foo dot Bar, and then
you run the To String
tear-off process on that
to get something
that will actually
be able to return the string
that represents that symbol.
So you couldn't know
which one it is, and there
is no syntactic way to say that
because the grammar is simply
such that it is ambiguous.
So this is something that is
handled in the specification
by actually saying that you
continue as far as you can.
Then the second example is
the function expression,
and I won't go into
the details with that.
But the point is that
you could actually
have something like this
expression that is here--
x to 42 dot To String.
Again, you could parse
that as the function,
and then you tear off
the To String method
from the function itself, which
is possible but never useful.
So we adjusted the grammar
to make sure that it's never
parsed like that.
And finally, we have
the example down below,
where you have something
that is an invocation
of a generic method,
but it also parses
as two arguments of type bool.
So basically, what's
happening is that we
have the specification parser.
It's supposed to help us
ensure that the grammar
of the language is
internally consistent,
so we have a correct grammar.
It's consistent with itself.
Second, we want to make
sure that we can actually
run this actual parser
on the source code
out there to see that we are
tracking the language as it is,
and it's consistent
with the tools.
And finally, this
specification grammar
is going to be used to
take the grammar rules out
of this ANTLR formulation
and put it into the language
specification in
a way that's free
of these accidental properties
and the extra detail.
That's it.
[APPLAUSE]